this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant org a
problem solving website that helps you
think like an engineer there is over
four billion mobile phone users in the
world a figure that is expected to grow
to five billion by the end of the decade
we've all become hugely dependent on
this amazing tool and the feeling of it
running out of battery is all too
familiar that desperate scramble before
he goes gently into the night these
devices last at best about one full day
on a church and then must spend the
better part of the evening tethered to a
wall unless you are constantly carrying
your charger with you it is difficult to
keep your phone from dying over the
course of a busy day but what if we
could charge your phones conveniently
without having to find a plug and
carrying a charger with us at all times
with the proliferation of electric
carriers and electronic biomedical
devices like pacemakers one vital piece
of technology first developed about a
century ago is set to significantly
improve the way we keep our devices
powered it's called wireless charging
and it's popping up in cafes fast food
restaurants and IKEA furniture although
there are competing standards wireless
charging is power delivery from a power
source to an electronic device without
the need for a tethered wire connection
inductive charging is the most popular
form of wireless charging for mobile
devices and leading the way is the
wireless power consortium with their Chi
opened interface standard using
fundamentally the same technology other
groups are incorporating inductive
charging tech for use in electric
vehicles getting to the bottom of
inductive charging you need to go all
the way back to the mid 1800s when
Michael Faraday discovered the
underlying principles of electromagnetic
induction he discovered that in the
presence of an alternating magnetic
field an electro-motive force would be
produced across an electric conductor by
the late 1800s Nikola Tesla utilized
this idea and demonstrated the
phenomenon of resonant inductive
coupling by lighting an incandescent
lamp wirelessly by shooting the current
to match the resonant frequency of the
coils the two coils would copal
providing higher efficiency power
transfer the discoveries that stem from
Faraday's led to the modern electrical
motor and other unmeasurable important
inventions however for inductive
charging the science proved easier than
implementation for starters there
weren't many electronics that would
greatly benefit from such technology in
the days of Nikola Tesla and due to
limitations in circuit board design and
size constraints
it wasn't until the 1990s in 2000's that
the technology became viable at the
consumer electronic level where we
started seeing wireless charging
toothbrushes and in 2008 wireless
charging mobile phones an inductive
charger consists of only a few parts AC
current from the wall an oscillator
electrical circuit and the transmission
coil the transmission coil is a tightly
wound copper element that as the
alternating current passes Tru will
produce the magnetic flux the magnetic
flux density is based on things like the
number of turns and the wire the
diameter of the transmission coil the
distance from the coil and other
properties such as current on the
receivers end the process is basically
the same except opposite and the
receiver device the coil of the same
type is embedded into the charging
circuit the alternating magnetic field
is picked up by the receiving coil and a
current is induced the AC power is
passed through a power rectifier and
stabilizers to convert it into DC power
the phone can use to charge the battery
both the transmitter and the receiver
have electrical resonant frequencies
designed to be the same for a load
displacement distances such as a mobile
phone on a charging pod it is actually
less efficient to operate at the circuit
resonant frequency due to heat
generation however for a larger
displacement distance such as a
chiropractor over a charging pad
operating at the resonant frequency
causes inductive coupling to counteract
some of the displacement related
transmission losses there are many other
factors that affect performance of
transmission and with no standardized
design on the phone's end yet
charging pads need ways of detecting the
type of device it is charging have
multiple coil arrangements and control
modules to alternate between modes the
two big questions with inductive
charging are once we keep coming back to
do people really care about the
technology and water the implications of
inductive charging becoming popular
having a fully charged phone wirelessly
but nonetheless stuck to a charging pad
is barely a convenience teams are
working within the qi wireless standard
to create devices such as the pi charger
which can charge up to four devices at a
range of up to a third of a meter with a
max power output of 10 watts per device
it's completely conceivable that the
office furniture of the future will have
inductive charging capability built in
followed by most laptops cell phones and
wireless mice but consumers need to care
about us and hardware manufacturers need
to see the value there is one industry
that inductive charging will make a
meaningful impact and it happens too
indirectly involve Tesla
again going to the petrol station is a
legitimate inconvenience and visiting a
Tesla charging station is an even bigger
inconvenience
that's why startups and corporations
alike are beginning to shift their
attention to this lucrative opportunity
similar to charging a cell phone on a
charging pad and transmitter would be
installed in parking spaces and a
receiver on the bottom of the car
imagine you're at ominous an electric
vehicle dropping you off for dinner and
seeking out a parking space would
inductive charging no attendant needed
the car simply aligns itself with the
transmission pod and the charging
process is initiated if these industries
can make this tech convenient there is a
huge chance people will want to use it
but is that a good thing according to a
study in 2015 conducted by the wireless
consortium the creators of the Qi
standard they found in real-world
conditions the Qi wireless charger had
an efficiency of about 59.4% with their
competitor coming in at just thirty nine
point six percent with 30 million iPhone
10 sold in its first quarter they have
an impact of 415 megawatt hours per day
if charged fully once per day with an
efficiency of only 60 percent that would
result in an increase in 278 megawatt
hour load on the grid which is about 25
years worth of power for an average home
this is only accounting for one mobile
phone and not accounting for the other
2.5 billion smartphones projected to be
in use by 2019 if all had inductive
charging the impact could be over 23,000
megawatt hours consumed per day to
produce his power cleanly the added load
would require an additional 1400 wind
turbines just for the added load with
electric vehicles things can get even
more interesting the Tesla Model 3 is
getting between 4.5 and 5.5 kilometers
per kilowatt hour depending on driving
habits with a daily commute of 35
kilometers the Tesla uses seven kilowatt
hours who are almost the same power
usage as a small family home so for
every evey on the road it's similar to
adding another house on the grid and
when you introduce inductive charging it
can equate to adding nearly two
additional homes national power grids
can likely accommodate this growth but
local infrastructure may not be capable
or even willing to expand their capacity
for the sake of convenience to evey
drivers a lot of the added stress on the
grid is based on the fact inductive
charging is an inefficient technology
but that may not necessarily be true
forever Oak Ridge National Library
only demonstrated a twenty kilowatt
inductive charging system that operates
at 90 percent efficiency
with power delivery up to three times
faster than traditional wired charging
although it's too early to know what the
real world
Walther battery efficiency will look
like it's still promising to see some of
the sharpest engineers in the energy
field digging deeper into the technology
and beyond theoretically it is possible
to transfer energy over greater
distances with electromagnetic waves
NASA awarded one company $900,000 for
its laser powered climbing robot the
robot had no power source onboard and
managed to climb 900 meters up a cable
suspended from a helicopter in just
under four minutes using a high-powered
laser to provide enough energy to solar
cells on its undercarriage this is a
fascinating technology that could have
huge potential we could have huge solar
cells and space beaming down energy to
earth her other satellites but right now
the power loss and transmission is far
too great to be useful and this is a
problem that is really facing current
technology on earth whether we want to
acknowledge it or not learning about
simple core concepts like this that
shape our world allows us to apply our
knowledge to real-world problems if
you're watching my videos you are likely
like me you are enthusiastic about
science and technology and want to apply
that knowledge to your everyday life but
to do that you have to truly understand
these principles yourself maybe you are
an IT professional and want to brush up
on your understanding of how computer
memory works well I have the perfect
place for you to do that you could take
the brilliant course in computer memory
this course is one of money you can take
on the site but today I'm going to focus
on what you will get from this specific
course because I took up myself and I
knew very little about memory before I
started the course treated me like I
treat my viewers I expect them to have
at least a high school level
understanding of physics and there were
terms in there that took me time to
understand as I puzzled through the
questions which helped me actually learn
and get true knowledge of the subject
the course checked my understanding
along the way and if I wasn't completely
confident on my understanding I could
check the solution which reinforced my
learning and corrected my misconceptions
I came out the other end with a better
understanding of how computers work and
why that information would be important
to a software developer my videos are
primarily crafted to inspire but
brilliant is crafted to educate and
that's why they are the perfect way to
wrap up my videos to support real
engineering and learn
more about brilliant go to brilliant org
ford slash real engineering and sign up
for free and also the first
seventy-three people that go to that
link will get 20% off the annual premium
subscription the channels views have
been going down lately and I'm not sure
why but there has definitely been a
shift in the algorithm and a lot of the
educational channels that upload
infrequently are feeling the pressure so
please hit the bell button and get
notified when I upload and do it for
your other favorite creators too